So you successfully learned about three different supervised learning
algorithms, now it's time for the fourth.
But this time, we won't prescribe one for you.
>> That's right. We're going to give you a choice of three, and
it's up to you to figure out which one you want to pursue on your own.
>> And what are the choices?
>> The choices are, k nearest neighbors.
Very simple, very straightforward algorithm, a great one to know.
Ataboost.
>> Mm-hm. >> Very powerful and random forest.
Those, those latter two are usually used with decision trees,
which you know all about by now.
>> Do you have a favorite?
>> I like eta boost.
>> Eta boost girl.
>> I love eta boost, yes.
>> So you're going to go out and
check on the documentation, pick an algorithm and run it, and report results,
and see if it can beat any of the algorithms here in about so far.
>> That's right, let's get started